bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de fileco consacré aux ressources
humaines on s'intéresse à une
association nationale qui vient en aide
au DRH pour les aider dans leur gestion
du personnel notre invité et Jérôme
voisseau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
président du groupe de la ndrh dans les
Yvelines alors avant de se pencher sur
les ressources humaines on va faire un
point sur l'emploi selon une étude
publiée par Pôle emploi et le credoch
dans les Yvelines les intentions
d'embauche ont augmenté de plus de 23%
en 2012 et les métiers qui arrivent en
tête sont ceux de l'aide à domicile des
agents d'entretien de locaux et les
ingénieurs informatiques alors on en
vient maintenant aux ressources humaines
la ndrh l'Association nationale des
directeurs des ressources humaines a été
créée en 1947 et compte plus de 5000
membres en France dont 80 dans les
Yvelines quelle est la mission première
de cette association c'est bien un rôle
de réseau alors la mission première de
cette association est effectivement un
rôle de réseau c'est-à-dire mettre en
relation des professionnels localement
et au niveau national il est également
de valoriser la fonction et créer de la
valeur dans une entreprise les hommes
sont la première valeur et la première
source de création de valeur et la
troisième raison est effectivement de
partager valider un certain nombre de
réflexions d'action en matière de
développement des ressources humaines
tout cela dans le but de contribuer au
développement économique vous êtes
vous-même des RH vous gérez près de 1000
personnes vous êtes président de ce
groupe depuis 2008 et membre depuis une
quinzaine d'années est-ce que on manage
un personnel de la même façon il y a 15
ou 20 ans et aujourd'hui
plus tout à fait puisque vous avez
différents facteurs vous avez une
activité économique qui n'est pas la
même donc avec des attentes nos patrons
entrepreneurs privés ou même de la
fonction publique qui sont différents
vous avez des métiers qui ont évolué
c'est à dire que je vous entendez parler
d'emploi tout à l'heure et notamment de
développement des services à la personne
les métiers de service sont des métiers
qui ont une quinzaine d'années
maintenant qui était beaucoup moins
développées par le passé vous avez de
moins en moins de grosses entités de
plus en plus d'entités décentralisées
donc ça un flux forcément sur la gestion
quotidien et sur les perspectives en
matière de ressources humaines pour
l'aspect économique mais pour l'aspect
humain est-ce que les profils des
personnes ont évolué alors ils ont
évolué vous avez l'exemple typique de ce
qu'on appelle la génération Y
c'est-à-dire que vous avez maintenant
des employés qui sont des ouvriers en
général plus jeunes puisque la
population sera jaunie qui n'ont pas les
mêmes attentes dans la vie qui n'ont pas
les mêmes attentes professionnelles qui
typiquement psychologiquement vont pas
se comporter de la même façon face à une
urgence face à un dossier à traiter face
à un défi à relever et tout cela influe
au quotidien sur la gestion est-ce que
vous auriez un exemple à nous citer
d'une différence de comportement vous
avez observé je vais vous prendre
l'exemple relativement fréquent vous
avez un poste vous prenez un service
financier vous avez différents niveaux
de poste du Junior qui va rentrer et
ensuite au chargé de mission senior dans
le temps le
l'intervalle entre ces trois postes
était de 5 à 10 ans aujourd'hui quand
vous avez des jeunes au bout de deux ans
ils viennent frapper à la porte en vous
disant je souhaiterais prendre le niveau
supérieur et si vous ne le faites pas la
façon de les faire patienter les
arguments à développer la contrepartie
financière ne suffisent pas ils sont
capables de vous dire ce que n'aurait
pas fait les plus anciens ben écoutez je
suis très heureux d'avoir passé deux ans
chez vous mais je vais tenter
l'expérience ailleurs alors le
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy vient de
se terminer quelle est la mesure phare
ou les mesures phares que vous retenez
alors la mesure phare et la rupture
conventionnelle c'est peut-être pas le
sujet ce n'est peut-être pas pardon le
sujet le plus emblématique en revanche
dans la vie de tous les jours et dans le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise le fait
de pouvoir mettre en parallèle un
salarié non plus en face à face avec son
employeur et convenir d'un départ dans
des conditions acceptables par les deux
parties et considéré par l'ensemble de
la profession des ressources humaines de
loin comme étant la mesure la plus
emblématique vous y avez eu recours
beaucoup plus que vous me pensiez ou un
des diablement oui puisque au départ je
pense que les employeurs et les RH
étaient un peu hésitants en frileux par
rapport à quelque chose de relativement
nouveau maintenant oui puisque la
rupture conventionnelle offre une espèce
de souplesse de liberté et d'échange qui
fait que beaucoup d'entreprises grandes
et petites puisque la mesure phare
concerne essentiellement les PME non pas
hésité à recourir ce type de mesure ce
qui est facile à mettre en oeuvre et
conseiller par un avocat leur a permis
d'alléger ou d'adapter leurs effectifs
ou simplement de gérer des situations
individuelles en temps de crise
économique ce que redoute le plus un DRH
c'est d'avoir à gérer un plan social
alors oui le plan social est avec tout
ce que le mot d'impactant et ce que le
DRH peut redouter je peux vous prendre
un exemple sur une enquête que nous
venons de à laquelle nous participons au
niveau de l'interfrage national une
dizaine de jours le plan social et la
mesure plus redoutent les DRH par contre
n'est pas le sujet de préoccupation
principale puisque même si on tend
beaucoup parler de plan de redressement
de difficulté d'entreprise le recours au
plan social n'est pas la mesure la plus
fréquemment utilisée alors une des
préoccupations principales ddrh c'est
bien la santé des salariés plusieurs
législations sont mises en place
concernant les salariés mais qu'en
est-il des entrepreneurs une étude c'est
une première en France vient de voir le
jour on regarde ensemble ce reportage
la première fois en France que l'intérêt
est porté sur la santé des entrepreneurs
il y a un an et c'est le premier
observatoire de la santé des dirigeants
de PME commerçants et artisans ceux-ci à
l'initiative de ce professeur
d'université qui avait fait le constat
du manque de statistique dans ce domaine
une réunion bilan vient de se tenir à la
Chambre de commerce chef d'entreprise il
se voit comme un leader donc quand il
s'agit de parler de santé il vous dira
jamais qui va mal et puis deuxièmement
c'est une population qui a plutôt
tendance à aller travailler même si son
malade pourtant leur santé est un
élément essentiel du développement de
leur entreprise
400 entrepreneurs ont été soumis à un
questionnaire hebdomadaire pendant un an
pour élaborer les questions les
chercheurs se sont notamment appuyés sur
l'index de Pittsburg qui mesure la
qualité du sommeil certaines types de
problèmes auxquels sont confrontés leur
occasion immédiatement une rupture
de problèmes d'endormissement ou de
problèmes de réveil précoce ce sont les
problèmes de trésorerie
et les problèmes avec la gestion des
salariés des préoccupations au cœur de
l'activité du Centre des Jeunes
Dirigeants partenaires de l'opération
objectif de cette enquête redorer
l'image de l'entrepreneuriat comme
l'explique ce jeune chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui j'ai une énergie que
j'aurais pas ou sûrement moins si
j'avais pas cette maîtrise de mon destin
mais la maîtrise de mon destin passe
aussi par les contraintes et le stress
lié à l'entrepreneuriat que chaque
personne chaque Français qui aujourd'hui
a un projet d'entreprise puisse le
réaliser et puis se dire que c'est pas
ultra dangereux c'est pas mettre sa
santé en danger c'est pas vrai cette
association créée dans les années 30
souhaite explique-t-elle recentrer
l'économie et l'entreprise autour de
l'humain elle compte 4000 membres en
France et une vingtaine dans les
Yvelines
Jérôme voisault vous êtes DRH dans un
grand groupe la pénibilité au travail
c'est un des enjeux majeurs d'un DRH
alors oui c'est un enjeu c'est un enjeu
parce qu'on parle de santé au travail et
qu'effectivement le rôle d'un
entrepreneur c'est de préserver la santé
de ses salariés au travail c'est aussi
un enjeu parce que il y a une attente
des salariés de mesure qu'on appelle des
mesures de compensation des mesures de
réparation de façon à prendre en compte
cette pénibilité et à faire valoir les
droits auxquels ils prétendent ce qui
est légitime et c'est enfin aussi un
enjeu parce que économiquement qui dit
durée du temps de travail qui s'allonge
10 facteurs risques importants pour la
collectivité et si rien n'est fait en
entreprise le coût peut-être reporté sur
la collectivité par le biais de ce qu'on
appelle les maladies professionnelles
les accidents de travail ce qui d'un
point de vue macroéconomique on prend
l'équilibre voilà alors vous parliez la
législation effectivement une directive
européenne a été transposée en 2011 en
droit français qui mise sur la
prévention pour justement éviter aussi
des dépenses superflues pour
l'entreprise de quelle manière
l'association La ndrh vient en aide à
ses membres pour décrypter ces textes de
loi qui parfois peuvent paraître confus
le premier élément est de décrypter ces
textes de réfléchir en commun de
partager des expériences ce qui fait
soit au niveau national dans notre
association soit au niveau du groupe
local c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
intervenants des avocats par exemple
vous avez des intervenants donc vous
avez dans le cas présent on a eu et nous
avons la chance d'avoir y compris parmi
le groupe des intervenants avocats donc
c'est eux qui viennent effectivement
travailler collectivement réfléchir avec
les moments du groupe quand les textes
ou le texte a été mis en place et arrivé
le côté psychologique et le côté
sociologique donc dans ce cadre là
l'avantage d'une association comme la
nôtre et permettre l'intervention de
gens issus de cabinet ou de consultants
qui viennent effectivement affiner
peaufiner la réflexion la recherche avec
les membres et la troisième ASSISTANCE
c'est que chaque entreprise est tenue
légalement de rédiger le même un propre
accord un plan d'action ce qu'on appelle
un plan d'action et le dernier temps
d'échange il est de pouvoir aider mettre
en relation après à une DRH ou or ndrh
les entreprises et les intervenants de
façon à finaliser cette cette mise en
place et cette déclinaison en action
mais on a l'impression que le DRH est un
un peu coincé si on peut dire entre le
DG le directeur général et puis le
directeur financier quel est votre marge
de manœuvre alors la marge de manoeuvre
elle est tout d'abord de préserver son
identité je crois que chacun a ses
propres contraintes le DG il est là pour
effectivement faire tourner une
entreprise s'assurer que les parts de
marché sont acquises et conquises infini
national gagné de l'argent le directeur
financier lui il est là pour préserver
et pour adapter à la réalité communique
du moment on est en phase de croissance
je vais être un peu simpliste mais il va
tendance à ouvrir un peu les
possibilités on est en phase de
régression une méfiance de les resserrer
et le DRH au milieu de tout ça il va
devoir s'assurer qu'une forme de
cohésion sociale entre ce que souhaite
la direction ce que souhaite les
salariés sans
froissertion syndicale et faire en sorte
que l'entreprise continue de progresser
de se développer alors on l'a vu la mdrh
permet à un échange de contact et puis
de compétences de connaissances mais
c'est aussi un moyen de trouver ou de
retrouver un emploi leur expliquer nous
comment ça fonctionne avec l'Alliance RH
alors qu'elle fonctionne par le biais
d'atelier
de conseils et mis par des cabinets
d'avocats par des cabinets de
recrutement notamment et ensuite par un
travail en commun sur tout ce qui va
être l'objet technique de recherche
d'emploi ça peut être de l'élaboration
des candidatures au CV à la notion de
réseau et ça va aussi et surtout être un
moment de partage et d'échange puisque
vous savez que nous sommes dans des
fonctions qui peuvent être exposées que
les conditions de la rupture donc le
psychologiquement certains de nos
collègues ont besoin d'un minimum de
temps avant de se construire et avant
d'être en capacité de se remettre en
recherche d'emploi alors on parle de
recrutement quels conseils
donneriez-vous à une personne qui envoie
son CV et qui voudrait se démarquer
parce que on le sait en 10 secondes à la
lecture d'un CV
alors il y a pas de vous aurez autant de
conseils que vous êtes conseillé ce qui
est un grand classique je pense que le
point le plus important c'est d'être le
plus véridique possible rien ne sert
d'essayer de masquer tronquer un certain
nombre d'infos c'est donner de façon la
plus synthétique possible et de partir
du principe que l'envoi d'un CV d'une
lettre d'un mail est une première étape
qui doit pas se permettre de passer un
cap et que le plus important vient
ensuite c'est l'entretien qu'on peut
avoir en face à face avec son recruteur
son employeur le cabinet qui vous reçoit
et c'est là où se fait la véritable
enjeu de sur d'un recrutement est-ce
qu'il y a des éléments qu'il vaut mieux
au mettre une photo l'âge
chacun peut avoir son école la petite
personnelle je vous dirai non puisque
lorsqu'un employeur va recruter
quelqu'un il va chercher une compétence
mais il va aussi chercher une
personnalité donc le fait d'être naturel
fait que entre s'il va y avoir une
candidat non retenue elle peut l'être
dès le début avec l'envoi du courrier du
CV on a alors le sentiment qu'on a passé
une barrière parce qu'on a envie de
mettre une photo on a oublié de mettre
ensemble d'éléments type age ou autre en
revanche lorsqu'on va se retrouver face
à son interview vert ou recruteur
l'élément manquant ou le point de
non compatible sera alors pris en compte
et de toute façon on arrivera même
résultat donc soyez le plus naturel
possible mettez les infos qui
caractérisent et qui vous caractérisent
le mieux et vous êtes toutes les chances
que ça se passe le mieux possible merci
beaucoup Jérôme voisin pour votre venue
en plateau merci à vous pour
l'invitation c'est terminé pour ce
numéro je vous retrouve le 22 juin pour
un nouveau fil déco